so here we have got a question in which
it is given that there is a triangle ABC
in which a b is equal to AC and these
things are given so let's draw the
figure according to the given question
and then let's solve it now basically
you know that angles opposite to equal
sides of a triangle are equal so if I
assume that this angle is X so this will
also be X because angles opposite to
equal sides of a triangle are equal now
we can use the exterior angle property
in this triangle if this is X and this
is X so this will be equal to 2x guys if
I assume this angle to be y this will
also be y because angles opposite to
equal sides of a triangle are equal